[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 journal dans
l'actualité départementale aujourd'hui
la primaire de la droite et du centre
avec le deuxième débat demain soir les
candidats se préparent pour cette
nouvelle échéance et notamment le député
des yvelines jean frédéric poisson que
nous avons suivie dans la dernière ligne
droite autre élection et autres enjeux
également dans l'actualité avec les
salariés des très petites entreprises
qui vont élire bientôt leurs
représentants syndicaux toutes les
explications les détails de cette
élection méconnu à suivre dans ce
journal et puis zoom sur un projet de
logement étudiant xxl actuellement en
course et randy city sur le campus de
paris saclay accueillera d'ici quelques
mois plus de mille étudiants mais on
ouvre ce journal avec l'annoncé du
ralliement de valérie pécresse à alain
juppé dans la course à la primaire
ancien ministre sous nicolas sarkozy
ancien député des yvelines est
actuellement présidente les républicains
de la région ile-de-france valérie
pécresse a dévoilé son choix dans les
colonnes du figaro hier c'est pour elle
je cite le seul à pouvoir battre à plate
couture marine le pen et à réformer et
restaurer l'autorité de l'état fin de
citation une annonce et une nouvelle
qu'ils interviennent à quelques heures
du deuxième débat entre elles les sept
candidats et justement à la veille de ce
nouveau moment clé pour la primaire de
la droite et du centre nous avons suivi
le président du parti chrétien-démocrate
et députée de la 10e circonscription des
yvelines j'en fais des jean frédéric
poisson dans sa préparation lui qui a
été la surprise du premier débat espère
confirmer lors de ce deuxième rendez
vous reportage de nicolas d'andré
terrorisme délinquance éducation des
sujets qui sont familiers à jean
frédéric poisson ces trois thématiques
seront notamment abordés lors du second
débat de la primaire de la droite et du
centre ce jeudi 3 novembre son très bon
rythme je suis certainement un de ceux
qui est le plus haut fait
2 du terrorisme et en particulier du
fonctionnement de dèche je suis un
universitaire donc je connais bien les
thématiques éducative
je travaille les questions
internationales des questions
européennes j'ai passé douze ans de ma
vie dans les banlieues sensibles ens de
paris donc je suis intarissable sur les
questions de sécurité entre deux
signatures pour la communauté
d'agglomération rambouillet territoire
jean frédéric poisson pense à la manière
d'aborder ce second débat je prépare de
la même manière que le premier ce qui a
fait la réussite de ce premier débat
c'est que je ne crois pas encore une
fois qu'il faille profusion de chiffres
le problème n'est pas de faire des
effets d'annoncé
j'ai une voix qui dénote par rapport à
la dominante
idéologique on peut dire ça comme ça des
représentants de la droite et du centre
en tout cas tels qu'ils sont engagés
dans la primaire et surtout j'ai voulu
essayer de manifester que les français
ont besoin qu'on leur parle de politique
et pas simplement de gestion son
directeur de campagne charles-henri
jamin coordonne l'équipe chargée de
travailler sur les thématiques et
confirme la sensation créée par son
candidat lors de la première
confrontation assez clair il a gagné 30
points de 30 points de notoriété en une
soirée ce qui globalement se fait en 12
15 ou 20 ans les objectifs du deuxième
débat c'est de confirmer jean frédéric
poisson comme étant la personne et comme
je ne vous le dira qui porte un vrai
projet une vraie vision qui
correspondent aux attentes
des français le premier tour de la
primaire de la droite et du centre se
déroulera le 21 novembre
politique toujours avec la confirmation
en appel de la condamnation de christine
boutin la conseillère départementale des
yvelines avait employé en 2014 le terme
abomination pour évoquer l'homosexualité
excusez moi la cour d'appel de paris a
donc condamné l'ancien ministre à verser
5000 euros d'amendé à trois associations
différentes dont le reste de l'actualité
une autre élection celle des
représentants syndicaux pour les
salariés des très petites entreprises et
les employés à domicile est méconnue
cette élection est organisée du 28
novembre 12 décembre prochain et pour en
savoir un peu plus sur le sujet miquel
et demi d'euros en plateau bonsoir
michael et dites nous combien de
personnes sont concernées par ces
élections professionnelles pour les tpe
alors sur l'ensemble du territoire ces
élections se tenir du 28 novembre au 12
décembre ils vont concerner un peu plus
de quatre millions cinq cent mille à
personne et notamment 90 milles dans les
yvelines vous le disiez nicolas pour
voter à toutes les personnes qui
travaillent dans des entreprises de
moins de onze salariés et également les
employés à domicile quel est l'intérêt
pour ses salariés michael de choisir des
représentants syndicaux alors c'est la
deuxième fois que de telles élections
sont organisées la première c'est et en
2012 et l'objectif est simple que les
sahraouis choisissent eux mêmes leurs
représentants des représentants qui vont
par exemple négocier directement la
convention collective de la branche
professionnelle concrètement il s'agit
des conditions de travail formation la
sécurité santé ou encore chômage écoutez
à ce propos les représentants
départementaux de la cgt et de la cfdt
aujourd'hui ces salariés n'ont le droit
qu'au minimum c'est-à-dire le code du
travail
de travailler avec les syndicats ça
permet à un moment aussi pour le coup de
jeu comment dire d'aller plus loin sur
la démarche de mieux défendre ses droits
de mieux effectivement pouvoir en
discuter autour d'une table avec des
patrons c'est la seule occasion pour ces
salariés de petites entreprises ou de
particuliers de s'exprimer de choisir
l'organisation syndicale qu'il souhaite
voir porter leurs revendications
ça va peser bien sûr aussi sur la
représentativité globale des différentes
organisations syndicales vous l'aurez
donc compris l'enjeu est important pour
les syndicats en cas de bon résultat la
cfdt pourrait devenir le premier
syndicat de france à la place de la cgt
à noter enfin que les électeurs auront
le choix entre une trentaine
d'organisations syndicales et qu'ils
pourront voter par courrier ou via
internet sur le site que l'on peut voir
s'afficher à l'écran élévation élections
en travail.gouv.fr vous avez bien suivi
nicolas merci michael pour toutes ces
précisions c'est un projet d'envergure
en cours de construction sur le campus
de paris saclay ses rangs d'ici du nom
du futur ensemble de logements étudiants
qui doit voir le jour est d'ici
septembre 2017 a été décoré d'ailleurs
ce projet le 12 octobre dernier à la
cité de l'architecturé du patrimoine
links city en charge du projet a reçu le
trophée hors du cadre de vie 2016 un
reportage d'haussmann vendeurs des ces
nouveaux logements à venir qui se situe
sur le campus urbain paris-saclay la
plus importante opération de logement
étudiant actuellement en cours en france
c'est pour cette raison que c'est rennes
10 city à l'origine du projet s'est vu
récompensé du trophée hors du cadre de
vie le jury a voulu récompenser
déjà le caractère exceptionnel de ce
projet par sa taille plus de 1000 82
étudiants qui habiteront ici aussi par
sa typologie et sa programmation son
aura une multiplicité de typologie on
aura des studios
des colocations de deux et trois
personnes ainsi que ce qu'on appelle les
t1 grappes qui sont une typologie
hybride qui permet de mêler l'intimité
du studio avec la sociabilité d'une
colocation et pour créer ce gigantesque
campus serendipity compte assembler le
campus en neuf mois
les finitions c'est à langon elle sur 20
mois un temps record la particularité de
ces nouveaux logements des bâtiments en
forme circulaire ça c'est un parti pris
urbain et architectural donc développé
par notre équipe de maîtrise d'oeuvre
lan clément vergély eto'o potec qu'on a
trouvé très séduisant et le parti-pris
urbain c'était de densifier la
périphérie pour permettre de libérer le
centre est créé à l'intérieur de ce
projet un véritable parc habité le
modèle c'est les jardins d'agrément du
xviiie siècle avec la figure les figures
du pavillon implantés dans des dans un
parc est donc ici la volonté ça a était
d'implanter 5 bâtiment circulaire le
nouveau campus de paris saclay ouvrira
ses portes à la rentrée 2010 est
dans notre série surnaturelle cette
semaine une légende yvelinoise qui va
vous donner la chair de poule à coup sûr
au château de rambouillet existe et oui
c'est sérieux un récit autour d'un
cocher décapité conduisant son carrosse
une histoire qui remonte au xviiie
siècle les explications de mélanie poker
romain russe pigné nicolas landry
les rangs bullet à entendre est encore
aujourd'hui le bruit des roues d'un
carrosse autour du château dans les
années 1770 un riche propriétaire de
saint léger en yvelines décide d'emmener
sa compagne au château de rambouillet
pour une balade en carrosse dans le parc
à mi-chemin dans un endroit reculé du
parc le carrosse s'arrête et donc le
propriétaire décide d'aller voir ce qui
se passe et là il découvre son cocher
décapité qui tient encore les rênes donc
de peur il emmène sa belle et s'enfuit
l'histoire vieille de trois siècles se
transmet entre les employés du château
c'est quelqu'un avec qui je travaille
qui nous en a parlé donc ça remonte à
quelques années quand même puisque
parfois il essayé de savoir en allant se
balader dans le parc quand il avait pas
beaucoup de monde essayer d'entendre ce
bruit mais je pense qu'il faut attendre
la nuit tombée quand même un point pour
l'entendre
le fantôme du cocher hante le domaine
royal mais pas seulement louis xiv sur
le dise ou plusieurs présidents de la
troisième république y ont séjourné et
leur esprit rôderait dans les lieux avec
tous les personnages qui sont passés
dans ce château on peut peut-être enfin
moi j'y crois a d'autres qui sont
cartésien n'y croiront pas du tout mais
moi je me dis pourquoi pas justement à
avoir des âmes des personnes qui sont
passés par ici qu'ils restent dans les
murs une histoire peu connue des
visiteurs mais le message envoyé par le
château est clair les curieux sont les
bienvenus à rambouillet la présence des
fantômes n'est pas tabou
on reste à rambouillet avec la trouille
et des citrouilles c'est le nom de
l'animation proposée par le château ou
lundi dernier à destination des 4 6 ans
il s'agissait surtout de déambuler dans
les couloirs de la laiterie à travers un
scénario forcément effrayant mais
derrière l'aspect ludique se cachait un
aspect éducatif pour la quinzaine
d'enfants inscrits écoutez à ce propos
l'une des animatrices du château
dans un deuxième temps valeur leur
apprendre les différentes expressions
corporelles qu'on peut avoir pour soi
pour faire peur soit pour être heureux
pour leur montrer comment eux vont
devoir faire peur aux méchants donc pour
ça on va dans la dans le salon du roi où
on a des différents tableaux sur les
murs on leur montre tableau on leur
explique que là le petit ange il a l'air
plutôt heureux là il a l'air il on a
l'impression qu'il a plutôt froid et
après on leur fait faire à eux des
émotions par le corps et par le visage
piloter sans doute le rêve de tous les
petits as garçons pour deux jeunes
yvelinois le rêve est devenu réalité
elle nicolas viard et nicholas hill
kiewitz sont revenus récemment du tour
de france des jeunes pilotes avec
forcément des étoiles plein les yeux en
reportage d'anne laure l'anguille miquel
et demi d'euros et jules grandes villes
vérifiez vérifie encore ne rien laisser
au hasard ces deux jeunes pilotes de
l'aéro club paul tissandier de
saint-cyr-l'ecole achève les derniers
préparatifs avant de décoller malgré
leur menu expérience le protocole semble
pour eux un exercice routinier alors là
c'est la jauge dite de l'avion
exactement comme sur une voiture donc on
vérifie que le niveau d'huile est il
suffisant avant chaque vol donc là on
voit qu'il est entre 5 et 6 c dans les
cédants les tolérances donc c'est
parfait
cette passion pour les airs ils ont tous
les deux découvertes alors qu'ils
étaient enfants
mais moi j'ai découvert le
l'aéronautique tout petit en fait mon
père était instructeur il l'est toujours
d'ailleurs et il m'a emmené donc je
devais avoir trois ans et je me souviens
d'un tour de piste que j'ai effectué
donc c'est un tour autour de l'aéroport
et ça m'a vraiment impressionné et vers
l'âge de 15 ans j'ai j'ai poussé la
porte de l'aéro club avec la volonté
d'apprendre à piloter dont je me fais
inscrits sied à l'aéro club paul
tissandier il s'entraîne depuis cinq ans
et ont tous deux réussi leur brevet de
pilotage un parcours sans faute qui les
a conduits au tour de france des jeunes
pilotes l'été dernier deux semaines de
vol de clermont ferrand aux côtes
normandes ils ont été sélectionnés en
même temps que 43 autres jeunes
techniquement au niveau du pilotage et
humainement ça a été super enrichissant
une des meilleures choses que j'ai fait
dans ma vie je pense pour l'instant et
j'en garderai toute ma vie un super
souvenir aujourd'hui à 20 ans passés ils
terminent leurs études d'ingénieur à
l'estaca est un film leur projet
professionnel
un avenir que chacun voit forcément dans
les airs et j'aimerais passer en
parallèle ma licence de pilote
professionnel qui permet de devenir
instructeur et éventuellement aussi
partir sur un métier qui me permettrait
de combiner de l'ingénierie et le
pilotage par exemple les essais les
essais en vol ce qui m'intéresserait
beaucoup
j'hésite à postuler pour pour faire
l'armée de l'air ou peut-être en
hélicoptère dans l'armée de terre et
voilà mais je me vois vraiment en a un
avenir dans l'aviation
en tant pilote des carrières exigeante
mais ce n'est pas ce qui stoppera les
deux intrépides yvelinois la difficulté
à tyr l'homme de caractère un jour dit
un grand homme
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de nous
avoir suivi tous nos reportages sont à
revoir en replay sur notre site internet
tv fil 78 points comme à demain pour une
nouvelle édition du 7 8 journal
[Musique]